you may not know this but i i did some
of the early research on anesthetic
drugs with brain imaging trying to
answer the question what part of the
brain is the last to turn off when
someone loses consciousness and is that
the first part of the brain to turn on
when consciousness is regained
and i was working with an
anesthesiologist named mike alkire who
was really brilliant at this these were
really the first studies of brain
imaging
using positron emission tomography
long before fmri
and you would inject a radioactive sugar
that labeled the brain and the harder
the brain was working the more sugar it
would take up and then you could make a
picture of
glucose use in the brain
and we
he he was amazing he managed to do this
in normal volunteers he brought in
and anesthetized as if they were going
into surgery
uh
and he managed all the human subjects
requirements on this research
and uh it was he was brilliant at this
and
and what we did is we had uh these
normal volunteers come in on three
occasions
on one occasion he gave them enough
anesthetic drug
so
they were
a little drowsy
and on another occasion they came in and
he fully anesthetized them
and you know he would say
you know
mike can you can you hear me
and the person would say uh
yeah
you know that's it
and then
we would scan people under the and under
uh no anesthetic condition so same
person
and
we were looking to see if we could see
the part of the brain
turn off
he subsequently tried to do this with
fmri which has a faster time resolution
and you could do it in real time as the
person went under
and then regained consciousness where
you couldn't do that with pet you had to
have three different occasions
and
the results were absolutely fascinating
we did this with different anesthetic
drugs
and different drugs impacted different
parts of the brain so we were naturally
looking for the common
one
and it seemed to have something to do
with the thalamus
and consciousness this was actual data
unconsciousness
real con actual consciousness what part
of the brain turns on
uh what part of the brain turns off
it's not so clear
but maybe has something to do with the
thalamus the the the sequence of events
seem to have the thalamus in it boy um
now here's the question are some people
more conscious than others
are there individual differences in
consciousness
and i don't mean it in the um
psychedelic sense i don't mean it in the
political consciousness sense i just
mean it in everyday life to some people
go through everyday life more conscious
than others and are those the people we
might actually label more intelligent so
now the other thing i was looking for is
whether the parts of the brain we were
seeing in the anesthesia studies were
the same parts of the brain we were
seeing in the intelligence studies
now this is you know this was very
complicated expensive research we didn't
really have funding to do this we were
trying to do it on the fly i'm not sure
anybody has pursued this you know i i'm
retired now uh he's gone on to other
things
but it's i think it's an area of
research that that would be fascinating
to see
the parts and there are a lot more
imaging studies now of consciousness i'm
just not up on them so but basically the
question is which imaging so newer
imaging studies to see in
high-resolution spatial and temporal way
which part of the brain lights up
when you're doing intelligence tasks and
which parts of the brain lights up when
you're doing consciousness tasks and see
the interplay between them you try to
infer that's the challenge of
neuroscience
without understanding deeply
looking from the outside
try to infer something about
uh how the whole thing works
well imagine this here's a simple
question
does it take more anesthetic drug
to put
to to have a person lose consciousness
consciousness if their iq is 140
than a person with an iq of 70.
that's an interesting way to study it
yeah i mean if there is if there is
a yet if the answer to that this is a
stable yes that's very interesting so i
tried to find out
and i went to some anesthesiology
textbooks about how you you dose
and they dose by weight
and
what i also learned this is a
little bit off subject
anesthesiologists
are never sure if you how deep you are
yeah
and they usually tell by poking you with
a needle and if you don't jump they tell
the surgeon to go ahead
i'm not sure that's
literally true but it's
well it might be very difficult to know
precisely
how deep you are it has to do with the
same kind of measurements that you're
doing with the consciousness with the
it's
it's it's difficult it's difficult to
know so i don't lose my train of thought
i couldn't find in the textbooks
anything about dosing by intelligence
i asked my friend the anesthesiologist
he said no he doesn't know i said can we
do a chart review
and look at people using their years of
education as a proxy for iq
because if someone's gone to graduate
school
that tells you something you can make
some difference as opposed to someone
who didn't graduate high school you know
can we do a chart review and he says no
they they never really put down the the
exact dose and no he said no so
to this day that the the the the simple
question does it take more anesthetic
drug
to put someone under if they have a high
iq
or less
or less it could go either way because
by the way our early
pet scan studies of intelligence
found
the
unexpected result of an inverse
correlation between glucose metabolic
rate and intelligence it wasn't how much
a brain area lit up
how much it lit up was negatively
correlated to how well they did on the
test which led to the brain efficiency
hypothesis
which is still being studied today
and there's more and more evidence that
the efficiency of brain information
processing is more related to
intelligence than
than uh
than
just
more activity yeah and it'll be
interesting again that's the total
hypothesis how much in the relationship
between intelligence and consciousness
it's not obvious that those two if
there's correlation that would be
uh
they they could be inversely correlated
wouldn't that be funny
if you uh
the um
the consciousness factor the c factor
plus the g factor equals one
[Laughter]
it's a nice trade-off
you get you get you get a trade-off how
deeply you experience the world versus
how deeply you're able to
reason through the world what a great
hypothesis
certainly somebody listening to this can
do this study
you